I want you to see something okay I'm
just gonna go ahead and say it for
anyone who just wants the quick version
I started a new Channel with my old Vox
colleague Sam Ellis the creator of Vox
Atlas it is live now it is called search
party it's going to be amazing you can
go watch it for those who want to stick
around let me explain
[Music]
get here so three years ago I left the
news outlet that birthed me as a
journalist to try to figure out what
independent journalism felt like I'm in
Mexico now and it's been quite the ride
can I get an ice cream cone
[Music]
this airport is completely empty
I didn't expect it to go the way that it
has and I didn't expect to find an
audience who was so eager to experiment
with me on what journalism could be and
how it could be different
[Music]
I'm really amazed at the audience who
has stuck with us during all of these
years as this channel has grown and here
behind the scenes I'm even more amazed
at the creative talented committed
people who make this all happen on our
team
[Music]
there tends to be so much Doom and Gloom
about the future of news and journalism
and yet that's not the future I see
every week I share a video with you and
what I see is a huge community of
millions of people who want to learn who
are interested in facts and truth and
evidence so I guess what I'm saying is I
see a world where more and more news and
journalism happens here with independent
journalists like myself who want to
continue to create work that maintains
journalistic rigor but want to do that
journalism in a place where they can
have a more personal back and forth with
their audience
this is not happening what I like about
this setup is that it requires me to
earn your trust
to be transparent about how I do my work
and what it allows for is really
exciting it allows me to get your
thoughts your voices your feedback on my
stories everything from voting on the
titles and thumbnails which a lot of you
do in the community tab to helping
critique my work so that it's more
accurate in a world that is becoming
increasingly polarized I believe there
is value in audiences being able to turn
to Independent journalists who aren't
beholden to the profit incentives of
large media companies I need to show you
a video that is blowing my mind
but wait there's a problem kind of with
this whole independent journalism thing
which is that the biggest thing that you
lose in going independent is colleagues
other journalists who will help make
your work better a story editor just
people to look over your scripts it's a
major drawback to not being at a news
outlet and it's one of the main reasons
I still do work with like the New York
Times so that I can get that feedback
from more seasoned journalists but that
is a problem that we're trying to solve
over these years is has worked really
hard to build a team she's hired she's
systematized she's managed the result of
all of this is now we have a big team of
creative talented people who share this
vision of rigorous journalism on YouTube
and to be clear this team is the only
reason we are able to make these super
long in-depth videos every week for all
of you I'm honestly kind of Blown Away
that it all happens but it somehow does
this is getting absurd I can't
journalism Studio that can be
simultaneously investigating labor
abuses in Qatar as well as watching
hours of North Korean Cinema or scouring
Financial disclosures of American
lawmakers while still allowing me to go
to the Swiss Alps to look for military
bunkers or in bed with remote
communities in Northern Greenland
putting on the heavy duty stuff here
because we're just out here on the ice
all day and it gets cold
[Music]
and now I'm getting to the point of this
whole video which is to tell you that
we're taking the next step forward on
our mission to become the home of the
best independent video journalism on the
internet let me introduce you to Sam
Ellis hey I'm Sam Ellis I mean if you
want to know Sam just look at his work
at Vox
Sam and I worked together at Vox for
many years he's a journalist he's a
writer editor designer animator and the
creator of Vox Atlas a show that has
brought international issues to millions
of people for the last five years and
all of that is in addition to the Emmy
nominated work that he's done on voxes
explained as well as vox's show Level
Playing Field on HBO he has a lot of
experience he's well sourced he's deeply
committed to journalistic rigor and
accuracy so me Sam and is have been
talking and talking and dreaming and
thinking and
the result is what we're launching today
foreign
this is search party search party is a
new independent video journalism channel
that is dedicated to uncovering decoding
and telling the most important stories
in geopolitics and Global Sports yes I
said Sports Sam in addition to being a
foreign affairs reporter is a giant
sports fan his work on search party will
use his unique visual style to explore
the geopolitical stories of the day
military economics diplomacy but then
we'll also apply that same lens to
Global Sports from serious corruption
and policy matters within Sports to
coverage on how Sports relates to
culture and history and identity Sam's
videos on search party will look and
feel somewhat similar to what you see on
this channel after all our separate
Journeys in journalism have had a lot of
similarities we were shaped by video
journalism on the internet we were
taught by some of the best New Media
journalists at Fox and were committed to
the same principles of rigorous
reporting and beautiful presentation
you'll even hear Tom Fox music and see
beautiful maps and we might even
collaborate from time to time and yet
search party videos will be different
they will feel like nothing else that
exists right now they'll be quite
shorter than mine and you'll see very
quickly that Sam doesn't appear on
camera much he works more behind the
scenes his videos will be much more
concise and focused and efficient on
giving you the best understanding of
complex Topics in a short amount of time
if you've ever watched Vox Atlas which
you should if you haven't you'll see
that Sam literally obsesses over
unlocking the path to deep understanding
of big issues he whittles down topics to
find the essence of the explanation and
then he presents it to you in the most
beautiful way possible so search party
is live right now the first video is up
it's really good I helped work on it
foreign
and if some of you are wondering how you
can support this here are a few ways
number one if you feel excited about
this big step in independent journalism
that we are taking tell people about it
post about it share about it whatever
the way our algorithmic driven World
works is the more people are talking
about stuff the better it does secondly
you should go over and subscribe and
watch these videos don't subscribe if
you're not going to watch that could do
terrible things to the algorithm but if
you are interested in this go subscribe
get notified and click on the video when
it comes out that is literally the
lifeblood of how our business works and
finally in these early days we don't
have a lot of Revenue coming in we're
looking for sponsors we're maybe looking
for Grants but if you want to be a
supporter we are going to have a
membership program for search party
anyone who supports search party will
get a badge saying how long they've been
supporting search party that badge will
stick with you in the comments and it
will show that you are someone who wants
to support this project who wants to
support good factual authoritative
journalism on YouTube and lastly give us
story ideas go over to search party and
comment what story you want to see next
upvote story ideas that you find
interesting we want to build search
party as something that the audience
wants and that the audience helps craft
that's how I've always done it that's
how I know how to do it that's what I
think you want that's how search party
is going to be built on that note
um I will see some of you in tomorrow's
video about the new Cold War this video
we've worked on for a really long time
and comes out tomorrow I hope you like
it and I'll see others of you over on
search party see you later
hold on
[Music]